batta
[Musique]
oh
on
bah
ouais
papa
au fond
[Musique]
jean louis
c'est quoi et puis tout ce qui passe
j'étais là je raccompagne et j'aurais pu
aider les voisins
voilà jean louis monsieur mais là c'est
pas ton frère
hautmont vespa
ça veut dire quoi répondez vous
ce sera pour toi vous on redescend des
salles a tout de suite qu'est-ce qu'est
ce que vous voulez que monsieur vous
promet des tortues à un autocollant des
tortues ninja oui premier tv
jean louis
[Musique]
vers 10h20
au 1
formé à parvenir les descendants
les études
travailler qu'est ce que tu veux un
jambon beurre
dans les faits passés à la belle et je
vais je passe moi
je viens lendemain nancy fait circuler
l'information choix j'en fais depuis un
bon mois à t'appeler après j'avoue j'ai
un problème là bon alors voilà je suis
chez la dame éditions et j'aime
sculpteur qui est cher monsieur on prend
la place de l'offre si ce ne serait que
pour moi je pense que jamais
c'est qu'on trouve
sur la scène n'ont jamais dit mais
j'ai déconné la beauté scousers d'achat
si monsieur monsieur deux premières jean
bauer tulle et d'essence toute heure
et s'ouvre les portes et on va
s'arranger pour vous apporter
un bémol
[Musique]